G'SIT AATREO AY W TNAYST I
CO WTIECONLH ITALF OOU YND A
EPKEHE TREET THETOD UR O
AU
CEEN.
WEA AV HE TLOF  OOPPELEAT WINCHG
EMAYBVEN TSIDCOTHE E TRUNY.
THFOYOK U R JNIOINGS U
YIFIK'DOU LNOTOE  KMOW REBO AUT
N
HINGOMIN W UGPE KIL WLPEE
O
IUNVIHI TS  TUARTLORNGHI F A
WTTLILEUTLEHI BE E  WAROWSLLY
TIANTRSIINONGEEO T RERINL  PNSO
HUGSBEN IN TAT LERSHI MTHON.
YO
SCAU NEE IT O ON S WUREBE.IT
INE ONTH N OGF YE OTIF I AOURE
U
R AEXARE N WWET EKGOARE E G
TOON I PSOERN- -T A ALLLS SOU
H
CHUR.
M R ELLEAY FITXCEDOR T'SIGONHT
EVT AND AOLSAVE W HAT GERE
WRSER INRSON CVEIOATN.
ROUER MODORAT IIR F T GSTOTO
IRETME VALLYAST HELLFA WNE W
IDID AGA FOR ARFON WDEUL
VENOL.
IFEN HOUAV'TEA RI  IDT
UD
ENE URCOAGDO TITO D O  SANATTH
E S WATHSANVCOERONTI WE HH WADIT
DAELID ND ANDAL HEA AF RYLL
WOFUERLVENT
IO OT G TIMETME HIR VALTULY A
O
FE JUREFOIONRS JDNES S U ALLWE
INSO PERN.
T THAATF  ITH NOU WLDE HOTAV
HAITEDEN WUTHO IT.
OU OESGUTRHOF NOHO HAS JTUS
D OPDRPEE  "ONTHRKW NEYO"IM TES
LLSTBESE LIS IIE BELVEAY TOD
LORIMETI WRTE TOR FAN AHETLCTI
K THINO LLWI GS WNDO AFEON O THE
URGNSIATECE PIES.
IT WLO GMUOW DN CHE LIK IST'
THYONECOMDTU SPIOLND A FW
THRYIS HTOF OIT POLALIC
OUDISCERS.
'SIEHE T PT  TCEHAROAMAD W
TO
THR ETL A ATIANCNG GNDOI
EREPNT IOT WHAE H H TASOAY S
OUABTHI TAN SSTR T AGEIR
TE
LIARE N.NGVI I
L WAMILNE B IRSON CVEIOATN FOR
40 4 OR M5 AUTINES IOU WLD
AGCOENURTOYOE U SKLL A A
QUONSF THQ&E A AND A
E
END ASEL WL.
IF YEEOU N CMOD REOFIEOPS HI TS
O
T AOKNDOUNKHA YORLL A F
BUNG AOFOP CY HE TOO BK.
YOUEED SOREOM MFOE R YROU
SIEFRND ANDY AM FILANUYO CET G A
NCBUH OHOF T ISENHE TT. CHA
YOANTHK UORLL A FAT WINCHG A IND
WIUR TNVET I OOUTOR  YO T
BE C TNHEATVEONRSN.IO
>>NKHAOU GR S UYFOVIHANGE M
BA.
AI'MEIT LTLORIT B M
BLORMFTAE A ASATOD MER.OR
ISSTY M AEUTND AETOM CPLAND
'T DIONENAV HE DJGHOU ASTIECVE
TOIBES DCRBU IET UEIT  G ASSLL
JU SM  AAYDAOO AIS GNDFRD IE
MIN AANE DRRI WTEHA T IT
AD
REMI.
WNON  OEW YK TIS"ME
LLSTBESE.ER
COTITURALAS.ON
IAN WTO TEIV DIDS THI
CO
TIERNVSA T TONO PAR.
NTI WAALO T TT ABK OUETH
CAINVOONTIS OFSDA AM'K BOO
BETHE USI ERK INTHE ARE
AY
I AND THINTHK EY A PDFOROUN
IND ANTHT  TGSHA'T DWEONLYSU UAL
LIHIO T TNKBO A.UT
AN IHE TNTOAN WT ABAL TK TOU
SOMAT A ARI WRTEAU BEC
TIMEPEOPLEEE S SNGETOMHISESO
ALIKEHR PN EAS IHRATTH PEAS
VENTWE EE.WHRYER
WBUTOPT HAPELEON D'TLI REA
S
WHEN CDA AME AMUPIT WHHA TT HE
WA TOI DNG ESSTIALSOB J A A
R
CLARY.IFCH IS TOIS DLLTIND A
SELKFOS EHIOM SETPE HNGAPNGNI
QUIT HSUE RE TOWOIV GE ITTEN
LANDGEUA AOSN  ITHE SRT
WO GADS AMEAVNGS  ULAORGEUA F
WHREE  WWE AYUACTLLIN SEEG.
SOMADANT I IOU CLDT  J'DUSKELI
RT STOTA R ADIEANGHO SER ERTXC
R
S TOMHIK. BOO
CRY LTIS TNT PHEOI
IT'S NOTT JUS THETHA T
PERSRAETTORURE A CEN TELO Y
ITSHA T ETHT EYITOYNJ WONH E
OTHE
THAY SHE TFE SUFF NGRI O
S
T ISN' HITE SAYS TRITHA BM TNGHE
SOMEN RE A IDEE THWIRUPE SCTM
NTWBEEESCDO ALENDCEEN A
HI S
INSMILE WHG ITDN MEANHE T
LY
PHINCNGAPTOHOGRTH OHSF
PUMRTUP SPOHO'SER WCEEJ ROIN I
GUE THANH OETHF OSEYO  DTH
E
ISNL UEHE TM.
THCREESHR INLTUEY RNS AWEO T
OME THATATIOF  OIS I--T HA T
YUECRLTHA TDS BTINOS MTMP TRU
N
E SHD ARFOORSCN SE TRHOT THA
THAT HE,RAMM IIGLAS,NT B
CKVO
RS TASONITS OUWHE M
THEMPATHE IZWIFNY A OSE THO.
ENCRE PSELI AEBIEX TTYO
E
CTHAT TELRUTYWOO RD D ANDDEE
THKEMAS  GEE FLD.OO
ES MITAKHE TM FLEE.RO PUD
ITHEESAK TL FMEE H
PYAP.
AKIT MM TESHEEE FLD.NI UTE
AS IG ONASES MTAKFEHE TM EL
TH WATAY WHE TYT L ILGEAYAW
H
HIANYTMA NNGO HAERTT W ITT
CO
NK T IHI TSEHOOR WDS SGNGTIIN
ANFYLA CRIS GIN AS LDCO AEYTH
EAREDFF OERENHA CLL I TGEO
D
COSAY RAEMNTPOIB LALER
RSSCDIOU MANE DVEBEAY EDEBRN OAR
TH AHA TTHAUTBO WENHAT PPS
WI POLNDYIC ANK T IHI'SHE TRE
A NEUN RHRNGNI TGHOUHI TSOO BK
ALATTH TUT AKSBORAHE T TALTIDION
NO W AONNDE SAWS THI ANDHE TN
NG GMOIHUO T SNDUPT  ASK A
ONESQUTII BUS T THINTHK
ES
CSOME IFOOMRTN THEDE IT TAHA
HIULY ORCOD R PAREWDIFPLEOE
TH CLDOUAK M G TEHEENEROVNMT
OTE EQUUNOTIOUN FCTTH INN REI
ILDAY LIV.ES
WTEVORSEELDOU S TDT HAAN
HT
DWOULCEEP RLANGEE FLISF O
BID Y TRAN EXISESM..TC
OUATWH YRGRE A ANNGUI IHI T
SBOD
R AOKNDINLLEAY WOOU YR
INHA TTEN CCERPTEIE,T' THASOT N
LYTUACALCTOR CRE
OY EEYNJHE TTYRU CEL.
ETHTYRU CELTS  INORO B AYP
,
IT'S P THENTOI.
OUOBVIATY SLTH KDINREF O BSAK
TIEXISIT PNGOLOTALIC NFNSIO O
HODDUYO ASSRET. I
IADAMRON WDEHA WTE W DF I A
PORTN IOPO TN IOOF
TETOECRAS NOTHERTHFOE R EL
ALSOCIAMRO PGRND A TOR FGO
HESO
ROALCI PFAMGR IEAT I MNT
EBOMEDYEOU WLDNIE  BPUEDSHO
ERWHE CELRUTYN S I AANEAIDL D A
FLUNHE TY EITRO AD.UN
WHF IOM SHONEEO WS IS WHETO
A SEE ACMODECRTHY ATES RNDPOS
O
A OABRDORLE ECTUPEAT STOSEPOD
DO
HO F YDOOUHECEOR TNT COU
RYTO
?THGEER
HA>> TNK Y T FOUORTHA
IN KD
ODINTRTION
K THI IN'MATWH INGAL TKIUT ABO
SIFOTHE E  ODIUNNG
THF E
TRCOUN OYFHE TOU CHERYNT W
RETH
A SEYAYLLRE AAT CREED EAL
AN AERTHEME TREREOUNDS AUNMOT
PL POFEO TFRE OMNT CHEOUH WRYIT
THAL IDE.
SN DOELY A'TPPMEO  TWON O
N
ATIMHE T TE.
JO T TTIUSFYU T HAYOOVEHA T
HASO R AEANOR FHY TSE LTAS
TINTHGSTHA YOUAY SHERE A T
RIOFT LL AUM H WITANY AHY
N RTCEAITGMSEENF OAN HUMSYIT I
NOEDTIENTL T TOM.HE
HIDAN TISS  A BTHTLATE
WAE
O EDNE T--GHFIT BEAV HE
TIGHNGS AN ANT COURY TIN SCEHE
BEG.NNGIIN
TH DDDFOERREINURG UCNSCOTRONTI
RID ANDU C TNGHEILIVSIG RHT
MONDNTME A YVE ERYR EAIN
BE
EETWN.
T IDFVEY HEGIOU Y UANERNDSTD
THME A FCARI'SGIRALE
EXMERINT WEMHIT D ORAOCCYYNL
RELYTA SEDRT I5  1N96END ANTH
OM BITECH  MESUCREMO
UNABTARSNDLE TTTHA IAS IS
VU AABERLES I ITS.
IT'SS THIIND  IDEWHOGOLY HIC
ATEAFRG LLLONDA PRESTE TMPRU.
CABASIATY LLWHVEE  WHAS  IA
N ATTUIOERWHEHE T STRTUREF OI
ROUYS SMTELL ASOW THETY PARO T
OWLDHO PHO WERITNI WUTIN
E
RIMAJOFTY O V THEE.OT
'SITHEDE IAL SPATHO E HAYRT T
E
TSESPREN TTHAUP GROEVT' IS
O
EN URERGTERO T PTHADSUE EM
Y  TATHEE ARON THE VGEER-- OF
ANUYO CEE TS WIAL DTHON
DTR
DP UMANIS HTO RHE SCRIINAYG
O TMHET' TNEHAG GOS IN
TOPR
YOECOTT FRU OM EINRYVETHG.
INM I'GOG P TO YTEROCTM FOURO
IBATWH LALERSRE A GONGOI T DO
WHHE TYET G WOW PER ICHHI
STA
RY EKEVEAWINTHG M  FAYROUYO
ATATTH MRSTE.
'STHATOW HOUP ND E UYISTJUIF
H
IKGSIN LE DANENISFRGISCHIN
RILST CONIEUEITNCSYND A B
TRVI TNGO Y ENOLTLROEROVTHWN A
ONECELTIL T  AALO ESTI TISTH
IDEA THETHA TA IRES IMEG LITEAT
GR T APNDUP GHEROERN  IAMAIC
HATTH L TASHEATITEGIMTSRIE GH
ANRME THPEENANT PALITOLIC A
CUALUREM HEGF YON ONIETH UDTE
IATSTESHIANN YTT TNGHA
THTHENATS A  IATS REATO
TH
TRCOE UNT ASY  INT MISEAO T
BE
AIT'SOLS DHES A TRYOU CNT
ITLF BUTE H WHEAS TTEAL TEN
DR
ONTIACTI OERHAF T OKIT NDF
TILICSSEEC BAU HCH WEATX "ESFO
" NEWS DEREVY R AAYNDDEAEPTE
WHE SA ON OX"F TEW NS"THA
TO AHE TSEESIEUDNCOUS B T
VA
NGDALITIHIHE T TATS NGTH
Y
COHAD MEBE TO WEEVLIE RE
BLONSPSIEOR FF LL A OETHRE
MSOBPRLEEIN  ITHE. LRIF
IMSO SOYPL TAY S TTHA THE
ECTRICOM SCRGLUGE RATEEAS SMCI
NG WISRO BAUECSE TUG SHETRE,GL
YOSIN'DOT OMLYMP CTOE
HE T
LUCONCITONSI, 'S NOT WIK LE
E
TSROBOON D'T TE IN ARO PAMGR
UD ANYO H REAV AN.CTEAIO
ATPE HAPNSS IMIOU YR NEORSFTU
ANOU YBL PRROES EMAR MDIAEDTE
HROTHUGALHE T VATS UETHAVOU Y H
N
CH WHIOU YAV HEOMEO
BEBOEEV A W TUTHET  TAYHAETH
RLWODKS WOR.
'SWHATER INTTIESNGS IISRU TMPM
COVENER D ANMMDEMAJOTY.
AGS INT'NTEL RIAN O T
ARIJOTYD A REANVELERSF OHEMA
AMANICRAEM DOC T ACYNDTHA
AFEOFRS KDINF OUT SOLN.IO
YOUAV HE ATE SYSCH WMHIAS W
EDSIDEGN UO  TBE IAINFR SNOAN MY
A
TOE MOR. FREAI
YOAV HEO T MAK STRLTUUCRA
ALS TIRAONT  TTOHA
STSYEM
USBECAONTHE E  WLYAYHA T
T
IEPARTSLY TRUNDES RPO, THENL O
A
Y THE C BNGHAESYNDES RPOOGIN T
ENFFDIER TS CEINOLIRHE P
IL
RPOWEEND A W TNO KWSHIAU BEC
SE
YOU AOO LKDETHT E ICCRMOAT
WHRTPAY  OH ICIS T ONEFHEOS MT
HYANR-PE- DME ACARIN LE ANDN I
N 3219 IGIE THBEINNNG OF2 193N I
LAKACS OT VER N TINHEEGTHOR B
O
EEC BOM OAR PTTHF E NEWL DEA
TH
LI CATOAHEONTI T LNIORAB U
ACBLKER VOTSHE TY CNGHAE
THE
SECOURHIF O TY PAS RTICH
THTIUNL  WENAS THE OAR PTY
FRA
PAALCI AHERTID I TOUHE STH
ATD ANTHRMS  IGEPL DIS
AYPO
RFWEUL A ITEL TLS H YOU
OWO
ULT UYATIMELEF DT.TEA I
YOVEHAAKO T ME IT--IK LE ND A
G  LASONAS TN Y HECAENWHER POW
HWHIC AHE TYNG DREOI NIG RHT
G AEYREO NGOI T
IDOT.OH
ASON LG AHES TY A CANHEERLT T
OTOF VHASER T CTHT EYRSIONDE
ILTETIGIMARI AMENSCA WHE TYLIL
UENTCOINRSO  TPUT TUEHAH. PAT
ON O THENEAN HDT' I--S NND A O
OTTHE NDR HEHAISHI TS BLRO PBA
H
FIRSTIMEN ICAME ARIN
ORSTYT  THAOAETH C TTILIONTHA
SEOPPOSIDHA TT  ILOEOGYSGS  ABI
AS
IST .
ASIT WTN'HI TS
IG B.
SNWA THIBIGN I96 18.
IN
IDHE T M T OSTFKL BHEAC
F
CETHE LLSIG RHTOV MENEMTON W
ETHATNCTLEIOUBND A STLQUSEEN
YO
LEREN -EION D TS T HAWAA
INGENUEAJ MYOITORY W  KUNO
I
?MEAN
NIARCHD NXOEPAS W RINSERENTG
D I'DRL DEAGR GYEOLLHIAPCAY
RIDIST ATEBUD.RIMECA
MORI AMENSCA- -RUND A T
MPRA
YLL NEREV HT MADOSCAME ARI
NN
IDHE T SSOE  TNNKHI I SE
WASHA TT' K THED INOF TNG
ITHATSOS RTF OEF HOP O AULND
NH
R OTE HENDHAS IG LONES  ATH
SYEM ESANNHCE TIT PHEOLALIC
UEINFL TE NCOF MOS
VANSCOERLEVETI EOFNTMES HE T
RAECELTORE TTEHES I NO WAY
--FO FORSHA WT'NG GOI OHT RNIG
O
T'>> IE LSIKDA U FL TBOOALMEGA
OTU YOSPHE TER OTHEA T
M.
TH>> 'SHT RIG.
THAC FT THA TTIRHEOW P IERS
AR
ALFITICIAN ELYNHYDCE BHE
POOFR  OTE SURYSSOFOM R
MERE
HEONAS TTDOY N'RO PSSCEHA T
AS OAUECSEFHI TSOGDE IOL
YWHVS
HEEER TIDCOY NSMS TERHE
ETO BNLHE T OY LATITEGIMARE P,TY
ONEYTH D'TEE SHA TT AS AN
AD
ENTVAAGHER O TNENE UAR
DAD
E NTVAAGAT IIS.
THACN I FSET E THEER OTHID S
E
RUAS TIN TMPAKNTADG VA
E AF
NGSAYITHHA TT  N AEYRE
OTEN
TLEDCH WHI REAYLLHE TIR
RPOWES INH E ACEAND AND
ATMODECRIC STEYSM.
I JT W PT ANTOYLAHI TS O.UT
ATWH YM  SOUEEPO BTOE TIINNGO T
S
THEDE IOFITNTY  DOCRACTI
RMREFOS LKING A T HTOW
HESE
TENA A ISONORPPTI T AEDLL
HEH
HAGSIN TYOT UD SAIUR
BA
YCASILL ANDV A.TAANGE
ETHUD A FNCIEEOR KHI TSDIN
OF
CR
LTUEY.
HAYOU VE TIT PHEOLALIC SONUAITTI
ERNOWHE D THETIOCEMRAYPAC RT IS
RSDIVED Y ITANATTH'S AD GOO
TH
RTF OHA TTVE ER CYIT AS  I--
O
E MCHANIN SHAO WISHE T
PRSINOS AF ND IVEU YOHA A
PAHA TT HASN A UDARNENE
ADFRAGNTE EL COMRU Y ATYND
ET
OTHEY PAR RTANATTH C'TYEA RLL
NEIT IITPP OOS IN IOORN
NSDEFEEMOFE  D TRAOCCYRS HUFA AT
HETAS WS  DREOEEAATTH L
U
-TLONGM ERTOAY SOTHING T OF
D
ENTVAAG ALS
HE>> TRAEM DOCRTC TIPAY
TSESPRENAJHE T MITORYUT BT I
ESDO HOT NUNE AVA Y OSEUR PPO
THOM CH WESIT AEI BNGERMA SLL
SMARRLE P ANDHE RCAUBEPLI
A
ESY RTDOEPOT N RSERENT A
TYJOMARIECUT B BSEAU O IFTS
NEMOHOGEYIT RN IGELIO
F--R
GIRELIEOS OUIDT GYLO ISHA A
YUNIT PF O TPOURSEET HATH
DE PATCRICOETYAR DAV'TSN HE.
I  DK,IN INO'TON KLYREW AL
WHNSHE T ARWE IS TH JOE
N NCMAHIDAN CNSISHRTEEN - A
-KR
SITIISN MAS. I
DUNG RONSTCTIONHRIS
S
WERE NEN AOTRDEVBET LI
S EN
ALRACIITQU EAL
ERE  CREWE APEPLOUE HOLEOP W
WE.
THTEUSDE SNSVEAU PLPT SUM
ER
BU WTHT EYAYLDOU SICOL PIT
OETSGH DMENOS T  YANOUE HAVO TRI
THE T PLA BCKMASOERN YRR YROU
A
.HTUGER
WE TRE AKIALNG TUTBOT.HA
WEKI TREALUT ANGBOLOC SIA
EQTY B THEE  CYAMTO
TADEUNRSNDEOND A PHIEPL T
F
14thND Th 1HE5tMEME ANDNT
SAOSR O MT U OFNYDOS  ASYWA A
THTGRE EA AOMPLHMEN
T
WTHEYEEROS PPARTAN.
THLIEP RUBARNCA P HTYAD
LOIDEOCAGILESNT IER
ITSN
FEDE TINNDGHELA BCKOT VE
.TH
REPLICATY PNAROTAS W N
VILEHEN I T WOU STH THOITUT
L
KACOT VE.
ANEMHE T DCRAOCTIAR PTYN S I I
I
POLAMIR  TTISIONOAYOD THE T
NTEXTE THA TT OS HIIS OF E
ONREASS WHYHE TRE PNTIARSA
VONG PIOTEROCT INSSOR S OTF
LODIRICUAU BUSEC THASOW HE W
HETGO T A4t 1hh 1ND5t
AMANENDMT OUIFD  YER W
TOINLLG IV GE VOETER POWO T
RDACCO IHA TTILLI W TNGOTERI
thE TH15ME A OMENDNT
OUTF
TEEXISHEENC W C INTES TTHE
RI OTSFLA BCKSOT VER A THE
TRTPAYMPT HASIS SLYEETS I
STTEINREINCOS NTO NGUI TCTSTRERI
THECELT A ARETHAO S TDO ITT
THAT VEBEO ES RENSPOIV
OA
DMOREERIVSE GFUPRO OER VOT YSOU
AKNOW PSOT MEOUNTOI YAV HEO T
DE, DEAVUYO HE TOEEC DIDHE WRE
THM CODERU S TOFHEISATENE
MOTAMP IORN TNTHA RHTIGS.
TH
CRDEE MON'S ATCAT DOT. THA
KNN'DOT UB ROWEPVOCALIN NGTII
CTSTRERINSIOIL W SLIXEE S
IN
ETHEATCTLEOR
ER'SAT C WINTALYHETHA T
E
TRONGYI TO D BON IUT DW K'TNO IF
THACIL WL  WALTULYK.OR
ATWH I SIL WLAYS IIFHA TT T I
DOES WT'KOR I LLES SSTHELIKY
H
EUB REPCALINAR PTYOC DEMTSRA
AVLLWI HOVTOE  MIDCOE NSABERLY
TTOHEHT RIGNTO  TCONUEIN I
ARTICIAL -LY- EATCTLEORE
T
NDOESRE ROTEPHENTSE TITAJ MOR
F
HE TOU C
RYNT.
WHEN HHI TSD PEAPNEIN THE
70s  HAD TOUMERENDS CT
LAFOR CKEEO PPL INTI PARLACUR
BEE E USTHPOOLWHE  AT INOF
DEACCRYS  IOLATTH PNSICITIA
ARNSES RPOLEIB T TOHEEO PEPL
DAN WN Y T COUANCEE AKA
N
P GROUOFEEO PPLND A IAK MESOT
LU YONOGEONRAV HBE TEO
REESIONBLO TE B
RASEDINFDHINCSEOPHA TT SEN
M
UPO TEI BNGIR THE RINHTIGS OT N
INBEGCTES RPE.ED
WIFEET GO T TT POT ISE TNHE
RIREST AIOCTNSIN ANDGAOT'M I N
SUHA TT AHE TYNG GREOI TO
WO THAS AY VERROAN DGE
USH
GINUL FL OOR--F  FHE T
VULEERLNABONSTUENTONS
H
DETHE ICCRMOAT RAR PTYONIEELS
SOW PER T ANDSEHE
TUNSCOTI ACIENESIA RREEL
ON
DTHETIOCEMRAYPAC RT D TO
ED
RTHEIIGHT
TDOI N'T WANKEO  TMANY A
TIEDPRICUTSON BT  J IUSN'DOT
T' WOWHAGGOS INO TN AP HPETBUN
I DONK THIA T' IS ANRYVE D
S
PLBE TEO .
>>M DAIS N JT US-- AND ELYAR
ON PHE WNSIDE TRUMPAS W
G NNRUINUYO OER WETH IUTN E
ELFID.
FEON O TNG THEHIPEI S HO T
ODI
HEUSSCS YO IRES TALK AUTBO
AG
N AIIN T ANDTE CHEEN IIERPCE
'SY SAITIDHI TS T  TEAHA
WEUN
IMREDESTEATT. I
S N'SOTNGETOMHILKE  WTABO A
T
ANAC BK HWAD TC AND ALYZE
WHAICEA RTDI CNANIDTEDA D
.WELL
HEENTH TTSUN PDIELAY S WL WAS
BE
TEUSCAE Z  CDRUSWA
ULRTPAICAR CODELRU T.AY
NT' ISAY AOT WT  THAE LWEIK
TONKHIUT ABOURSEES BUT I
WOERHE WOUERTH YELOU YRS
E
GHTHOUH MTUC ABOTHHA WT
CTALPE AISLLUAY OTND A NUS JTP
M
BG ON-- IUTF YOUOO LK A Y
A
NEE SEL CRU T ATYNDOOM S
EEX
OUNTTE Y CAN SEEHE TRUEL
TPEAPALLEPEO OP WND A IIFDEONR
UYOOU CLD TKALBO AUTHE TTAR TGE
OFHE T M.SAESGE
NK T IHIKET  IMA FTHS EM
S
GHTHOUHE TYEL B AGEOND IT
MAM TSHEPOEE FL  ARFWEUL
T
SMAKE TMHEEE FLBO APL PVEEOWHO
NG BEEICT AEDN. UPO
IT A'SITEP DOL VIZICED OSIERON
H
.IS
EV HIFE N BEREE A YHI CLDOU HEAV
SEOOHE T CS KLIDO RY T TKEMA
FUTH ONF Y NEE RDDS ABE MAY
YON INJO IE CABEUSNTU YOWAO T
T  PBEAR C TOFHELOOID KSUP GRO
BE MORAYREOU Y AF NE O OREE THRA
FE S WHOP CKTI UE R FOTHDKI
GEO'WHS INTTGKE PICD OMA ONR EYB
UYOY STAT IL SENE CABEUSU
DO TWAT NTHEBEO  TEX NT
RGET
DAN THE--ID KS  THEOO C
KIS
TEARE  TINASGDY NHEERHAID KS VE
O
CEDRM ATYMUOMNI T TOUHRGHTHA
ACT OFHE TY ANG DREOIHIOM SET
Y  TATHET E ARNOPPOS
E
GDOIN T AND BY'HELLWIDEOND
OEACHERTHR OVEIR THERE SHA
DCR
TOLTUEY RDWAS TERSHI PN ON
UTETH O
DESI.
IWHATS DTOET IRE CESAT AN
UPN-DNDOWFIUS JTI THE
BE
ORVI.
ALLUM HANSEI BNG CRE A OABAPLE
H
D  KISINOF C.ELRUTY
IED TRISIMP EHAS  TZEHIIS NOT
GTHMEIN IHA TTT JSUS
BO T
ERCONSS TIVAVE R TORHEUBLIN
Y.PART
I R CANR EMEMBEENWH IAS W
SI MG ININE HOY USAS TINEX
DU THEREEZG GOE INHROTHUG
MCISOALNDIAED A I AMLICR SOL
N
D IWEEE S TOMS ETFRPL PEO
HA'SAT W G YTOU V FETORINOTGETH
R AOTBBT.
FOR ME,KIHA TT NDF OEL CRU,TY
STE THDINCTINIO BWEENHA T
UH ICYOEE SE T  ATHLEUMTRP LVEH
T TISHAHEEM DCRAOCTITY PARY B
ORTVIUEF ITSER DIVOETYSI D
T
VEBEHA TAYTHA WDSOW TARHE T
TIPOOPSION I SOFOCAN LIASIARN W
OLNGVI RNGLI BTSCKLAOUED T
NDUZCR AN S I ORITTWTENGAL TKI
ABFOCAT LIS IARN ILE FAAID
ATSTE.
EXENWH T WASASIN HAVITG SAC LK
HETSOU TOR WST10 IN EA YRSHE T
MEVEGORNTH -NT- RNGOE VE OF
FOCALIILIARN WLAS WE LIK
EST
ESWISHO T TAS AWI WNDE LLP HEL
HOMPA ARCASER NAU BOTEC
S CRMOATEARVIOR ME  IUORTUSSEDS
WUSCAEUN HEYO AIA RREEL
N
AIV DSEERLI COAOUONTI YTRIL WL
O
IN W PPLEOEVE OR AEND WAN C
LOATT  ATHGHHR TOURYIS HTOND
AN CEE S THE WREOC DHEEM
C
Y PART TS WAINSIT HAPONDONTI A
LTCRUETOY  C HATREEINDAR LSF OWA
NTWBEEE CHE TIRTYMUOMNIHEND A T
ONHEATTH TYAN WD TRODEO ST
O
W S WE TEEHEEP RNLIUBCAARTY
N I S A PILIMARN ITOSIODANS I
BEITNGVI WH TINTHA KOFD
PTNTCOEMAR TOWAN HDSUMSEI BNG
AR OUTFDESI OTS ILI COAONTI.
TH
A IISSEN ENSSARALTI POFT
NMAHUN AURATE TNDHENL OYOAY W T
PR FT ENITMRO DOMGATININ
ITILICSAVTOS  HYS AE SMTEPO
DTHATHEINIMISRETHS E RD F
NGGAENGIN I IT.
T>> I OUGHOHT CCAF T ALIALNGS
AN E WMPXALEREHEEN MGE FOR
ITMMCOUNY WOMHIT DANCE
AT' IS ERE GAT.MPXALE
Y T>>HEMOE ARALKI TSTAL TNGO
EA
CH O
ERTH.
EYON'T THI TNKE T HAON
O
G INTOPO RES.ND
AVEYTH HRPOE WER OVENDER H A
SHGINHE TS BIROYTHHA TT EY
E
KITHE ND OF P WSOERN D CHOAN
OTH
.IS
AATTH'SRE GATXA ELEMP.
DOWH Y OU Y IHI TNKT IS -
-TR
PUM D A NIDOTLL O AFUD SNDE
ACMECO RT.
ITDAR MKEARIS H CNCR EESI
S
ANENTRO ICENT THEUB PROCLI F
M
SUINBEG EDOUOR F HNGSI
NARISCMIYONTI BHE TTI JUS
NTRTPAMEP UO TNGAL CLIOR FHE TEE
PEATDEH FOLTNAY CETHR E RANTL
PA FEIVND AHE T'VREEEE BN
SBOOKENRI WTT HBO AUT.. EIMTC
ITHISNENOS T
Y DO T YOUNKHIT INDAS W A IT
T GOTO A PNTOIRE WHEEO PEPL
TLLCAEDACMPRU R.  EESTC
TY
T POIN D WISHYOOU YHI TNKAR WE
O
TAES RISSP TNTO  TK EATO
ALPEF O AHA TT TNDO OPE SAKFHEAP
TH
UA AATCTLIT POLALICIT POSN?IO
EOHY W PEE PLARHE T
APMODEGRCHIITAJ MOR T AYNDYHE
O NDTE TTE BBEETRFF O OHA TNERTH
ATMODECRSOS S AMEON CSUY TRSHE
HA L AOT O AOW PERYO INDF
UR
E AAI MMTRNSEAAPEW NSP OERR
NEWS C YNNHAEL'T DOUONANT TO
AL STENA A OTIECONFOU Y
RAU
AENDICES  TNDENLI MOFIL
F
LEPEOP VOT FORHE TM.
SO'STHF ATHE TYOAS CE U REAYLL
TDON' TAN WTEN AOLIESE ATTH
EPE
LEOP.
IF Y D ARET OCEMRAGHU YOMI
EO SEDOMVO TNEO TEOR FNDOU Y ANE
OUIF YTHRE A "YONEE W  TRK
"
ARYOU AVTOE  HA OUN BCH
FLI
RABELRSEA RDE
TWAU NT T GOETEOSEHE POE PLWH
DDIOT N CRENTPO SUP YRTOU
YD ANIFGE SOUUGT  TSTHA
CM
HASHIOM SET TNGOITO D WOUITH  Y
ARG TTPUINLFURYOSEN I
APO
TTISIONOE LOSHEIREY MON
TRIR TTSHERSIE VWEPHIEIN  ITH
E
ERSH AND IEL BVEIE
AT
T FIRSATTH IT OOE DSF THIS
INO  E
ENTCEIV WT ING GASOI
HVERYR D ARFO TOPPELEOOO LK AT
I AITND WHI TNKTHA HAPISNEPED
ALWAUMTRP SO SELO BNDOND A S
RETITIVE WBO AUT
T HAHE
EVBELI W AEDND HHYEIE BELDVE
T
WHAND HEY HEID D TS HI TNG
D
ITHAT OTENSADFVE EYUANTLL
SOPPELETDAI I ISHAT . WITAS
COR OO BKENG GISOIO TOM CE I
THAND ATREENHE TWIOU HSENS,VE O
ONTHE E HT'DAN IS SOBS AHADUR T
T
IEN LDSTOELTSF NEOM SEOEI BNG
KE HEYT' ISO ORTVE.
AND INK THIHA WTES T'INGSTREIN
IS IHI TNK T DREHE'SEMAGISRETEN
OUABTDOHA WT RULDNA TNK TMPHI
S
ANT  WDHAS. DHEOE
THT S E'NOOFLOA T
DINTEEGRMEWE BETAB UENS TOU
WH OHEETRHINOR T ENAUS DI
CEEN
RUYSJO COWTYEL TDSAR
DUDIINVIDS ALANERHE WTH OR NOT
CERAS IAR A PISOFT  H TIT PCHO
HIER VOT A ASNDERFT CE H
LD
NCOLI KICPEAERNK - AAIHE-  SMYD
OPLE TOV LEUFS HISTF.
THEESADIGRNTME T IEANKHI RYLL
WE BISET,EN NOTENET BWEDE  MAN
LDDONA ORU TMPDONA TMPRU A
D
OMOST HFIST- LEFRINGWI C
C,
S IT INTWBEEE CHO TSE ATIRICSND
INTHE  OSTDURYLEPEF OPN I
NTWBEEE DRUDAL T WMPHO
IKE
LDDONARUMPND WT ANTOUP SRTPO
NDMHI A TAN WTTELLHEMS
S
TTHATNG THEHIREWES  A
NGRISCBIOTRE A NHA WT TYHE
ARE.
..
T ONEFNG THEHIS IOV LE
ABT ASMDA A HEAS H G
ATRE
ITCLAR H IYNISRI WNGTI.
I W TASKIALNGBO AUT THE TOPF O
THLE TEIT.
LL RATEAYS IHE T J.OB
D, AMI T'TONOET GOU YNT IO
TO M THUC HUBROLE IE,ER
NLRTCEAIW KYNOGHHR TOU
ERCONVSTISAONOU Y HEAV A
HYOSILOP HBO AUT TOWORI WTE.
ERTHNSE' A LANAGEOR F
INFCEAN OECT AIVES NNHE TRE
IS AAN L SAGGUE LEOOMNE YEIKOU
THAT RES.
TH VS IYER DNTFEIFRE.
AY AILWED LSIK PHI TSTIORONF O
THRSON CVE IIOATN ITSEV NER
CAE SET' THA ISNHE T
AU
CEEN.
DWOULALOU Y T A LTLE
IT B
URT OUYOLO PHI WPHSOYOUTHA Y
EARGRY TINO TO D AND HOW YOU
TDO I L ATLITE BIT?
AIVEI' S P TDHEEATAS Y I
PA TULICAR AREHE'SK BOO
EDCALL RLA BCKRUONECST
IOCTN
ICAMER
D IT IE HAY SS AT THEIM T
E
HE IS WTIRING T MHENAIMTR SEA
HI
ALORSTICNSON CSE IUSS
RETITRNSUC A WONASC,RA TGI
FA
IT WASRU CORPT.
WITAS QUOTERO NEGRN TIE.EY
IT
AS W A M TTAISKE
O
ANENFRBLISCHE N.K ACME
TH TOREFE JHEIM C SWROTEYSM
ISNALMM IORUSTIED T
O
FTHATLIOOSHIMXP EERTEN.
W HDE ITERIS HN BISKOOE' HS
LI
KE TSK BOOS I FORPL PEO
E
TWHOLANKHI BPL PCKEO AERE
LEPEOP
REEYTH AUST AS CABAPLE,
NTTALE AEDNDLA F ADWE OS
ERTH
HUINN MABE.GS
YD ANIF N DOUOOTIE BELVES THI
YO NWIU LLOTE BBL AEO TEA RD
ANSTND UERHIDAN TSK. BOO
ADAN IOTM NN EVERY TOGIN T
CO
YINNVCEOU YF IRET THA
.RSPEON
WH I AMIN TRY TGOO D IS
ITERUHE T T.TH
ORDAN F MEN O THEOL RE IOS T
UAPERSPL PDEEO D WEHO NOOT
ADALREEE AYGRIT WH USO T AEEGR
TWITHS.HI
INOKUT OLO, ITOULD BEIC NE
HAIF TPE HTAPD.NE
'T DIONHI TNKHA TST I J MY.
INI THDA FKUNLYNTMEALT IY M
SBJO IARIM SILO TTIBJ OECVE
JOLINAST I TNHEEN SSET THA
OBMY J IO TTE WRIHA WST I
HA TINENGHEES BT I CANO S
HEATTH TNCUD AIE TE,HEUB PCLI
AKNCA ME AEC D OIOISNN
WHNFEREV IONMAORTI GHE TYET
FROME MHA T TTYHEEE FL LEIK IS
US
ORULEF FHE TIL FFNGLI OY M
SJOBN DETOW A RORECD OF
TSEVEN IHA TT ASSOS M
ACSTERA A C IAN GET IT.
TONOT NT PLA MYENRG AUMT IN A
TWAYTHA I T WNKHILILAYOR PTR
,E
TUARSDEUPMPRU SRTER TO
SEYT I MAY W.
HINK IF YOU DOT THAOU Y
MAULTINDLYTE EP UIS R TNGKITHA
ILUYO WLE BIS D INEHOSTOUN Y
R
AR BMEGUNT YAUECSET WOUANO T
BESU PERIVASE
.
THER IS AOS PTYBISILIOU YR
NTGUARMEECOMOR CPTRUED BY
DYOUR TIRESEOPP AOLEA T T
ETPOHYTHERALIC PHONSO WS DOE
TNOEA ALRGRDY A WEEOUHIT Y
DHE W YERTHOU AEEGRH WITE M.AN
OR, NOTHEN I'MIM SYPLGRY TIN
TOOS I DECRESIBHE TSVE ENT
AS
ATCC AURSYEL ASI POSEBL.
ANOU YW, KNOES HONYTL NOT
ODEREVYBLS FYEEHA TT. WAY
FILEE TTHAT' ISMP I TTAORNTO
APHECHOA THAOB J T WTAY
BE
IUSCAEPS HTELENDIV GES
ME ARI CLATYOR FINOC FUSG ON
ATWH IEN WOT TAY S.
I'M TOI GNGO USET THA AND
GI'MONGOI TAC BKP U ATL LITE
BI
T.
WSOREHE TREHERE A A L OOTF
BOOK Y ISNOUROU H?HOSELD
S, >>YE L AOTF O BKSOO A LOT
OF
KS BOO.
MYRAT FHE WKEDOR THETE STA
MEPADERT M MNTY WHEOTR
KEORD
THFOR ETH SMINIAN.
IBNA[IUD]LE
THDAL VUE KHA TTFDIN O
NGARLENIND ANO K AEDWLGE IND
MET N'REERMB M PYENARTSUS JT
GI
ENVE MHILDN'S
PHOGBIRASIE M OFCOLM X AND
MEMOHA W ADLINHE I WASE LIK
SI
RS YXEA OLD.
AN IT' ISTIERNTESAU BNGEC
SETH
N DEYIDES NOTECRISALY TLEL
ME
HATO TNKHIBO AUTHO TSE
TRYI S TNGOYPEHA M CEERARLELY
NDRSDETAFGIN OHE TLD WOR.
D SOES IRE GWP U IN A
WIUSHOE OT ATH LF O BOO
.
IAND  EAS WDECXPTEO TEA RD A
LO
B OTFKSOOS A A.HI CLD
>>IDt:os DNJOU Y E T AOYTHE
METI?
NOOU Y KID IW D
ITUC MHRRRE PFEEDIC COM
THSOK OERN THA TOOHE B MKSYO
SREPANTDAN WTEOOE M TD. REA
TEAU[LGHR]
I W AASME TRE ROUNDS ODEEAR
F
CCOMI MOO BKSHAEOR TNTH ANYGIN
TELSE P TOHE TNTOI ITHA MFEYPAM
TANDLLEAK AF OHE T CM ROICOM
SBOOKYN I MM ROO ANDHO SVE
NTEMTH IO AOX B ANDAK TEHE TM
DT OUANET SOU Y GETSE THE BKAC
WHIKOU Y L TEO FISINHER H
HO
.WOMERK
[LTEGHR]
T WWEENIN WSD AHE T L
HTIG
CHSWIT OOM CE WN,AS T FHESTIR
MO
OUNTME YRE AE LIK INK THI I
ONCA DHI TS IF Y GOM FRO
TADREERORI WR?TE
SATWH IHE TESAR ELITTOM MEN
YOAN CBEEM REM
I>> EDTA SRTFF WTINGAD B
RYPOET OUSN B IESNNGAS WHINTO
C.D.
AN IEN W TTO VSAASRGEOL CLE I
MA
REDN E WLINGSHAS
UNFORTEATNO EHUG TAV HE A
GR
VET EANONDSTLI ARIEM MOI
STAS
A TCHEAER.
ASHE W A VYERTAMP IORNT F
CER
IN LY MEIF IN TMS O MFINAKG
MEBONKHI A HUTOW TOE B A
ERWRIT.
DOT? IE HEL T YLOUOU YLD COU
ESWA H T FHE PSTIR TSOERN SOAY
YO AAN CUALL DO TSHI?
>> WEASRANC EOUNGGI, HE WAS
RE
ULECSPTFHAF O WVETER IT IS
YO AUREGRY TINO TO DH WIT
WRG.IN
HEOU WLDSK AIOUE QSTT TNSHA
WE
NT MREEA GO T YDEUIOUN I
THATIREC HONTI,IDE DOT N
GIOU YRSNS AWE.
BE TEUS IISNKHI H
OPILPHOSND,HY A IOP HE N'MOT
MI BTITANG HUTISSOHI PLOYPH
SWAE HTE WAN TDOUI GOUDE Y
SWATORDRIHE T WOURTE YTE WAN
DTO
OTE B N THETE WRIT TRHA H
TMIGHHI TNK YOUHO SDULE. B
ANNARI OGI AY,LL IYUACTLL
WA M TEDOEAK DOCENTAESRI.
TH
AT IST WHA IEN W TTO
LIURJONAOO SSMCH. FLOR
BUAS I WO ALSGG BLONGIN O THE
TDESI,S I DATGINEL MYSF.
WAS00 2--7 8 200CH WHIAS W
SENSATLO BG ERAN I THEMA AURTE
CT'SAT A HLLUAYOWE W. MET
B HIAD ANEE RDEEARFOURS
IC NDOT H YEDOUAD A B
G.LO
REYOU' TUS JT YINRYGANROU H
AT
BGGIN.
ATTH ISOR STF O WOW HE
OR MALINLY WETAS TN OHE
TEINETRN.
CTH EYEAR AHE  BANE.RERE
CTHEYANE B.
ASI WLO BINGGG IT WN'AST
ILHEAVY TKEFFRAIC
ODR
HIANYT.NG
ERE THAMROANIC P AECSPTEEDSK M
TO BET G AGLOOR FHE TSM A I
WAUAGRS ADNG JRNALMIS
.HOSCOL
I GNOANT J AETNYNSOB I
DOMENTYAR.
OSTH AJOE BS P IRENLIUBC
VITELEITONSI WERH CIN
CO AIEANS A NREOTOT LF O
TH
RE TEMHE TAR HDOET G.
ETHRI AMENCARO PECSPT SLLTI
RE O MINYIT PWNOLALIC
E.VOIC
TH'S WTHA IEE FOL S PSCIREOU
TABOUINAG MAZ IESNENERAL.
TH YEL HP SOUEEH WITOU YR
EYE.
ANDIR HEME TUMO DOHI TS TYHE
REWE ADE WONULRFUN GRO FDOR
COEN YAGUREOUO TOR REP ATNDE B
UT AENBOR YOUER P
NASOL
LOIDEOCAGILSP PERSTIECVEHE WRE
IT MO T TETHA WHEAS TIN K ODF
LIURJONAT TSMHAYEA RLL
APOEDAL TE M.
ODAN S IAS WNAOR FTU TTEO
TSTARITFF O W P THHETSPROEC
MAA ZIGANE THEHO TTSHTUG IFEL
I HOFISCTELNTLELUA PROCTJES.
ANDT THAAS W AOK CROH. PEDAT
IT A NASOTERYTR SGHAIT
OKCALI W W UEPHENHE TD SYAII
TE WIAN TDO AE BALOU JRNTIS I
WOHEOR F TOO SCHLAP PER.
A WITASTAIDCCENUMYLL TEDBL
TTOIN ITND A IDUR TNEUT O TO
BEDIEW RAREE CNGAR FROR ME.
I OR F INATUTE TNAYTHA W
.
CIESPEONLYAL CGRNCEINHE T
OFATSTE HE TUS INDHEYTR TRE
OTEAR NANS A M JS AS ID USE
ETO B WHORE A AUS JTS TDENALTE
AS AMUST IN D ANTFEIFRE
RE
ONGI.
VEE FLY GTEHELFU WRE I
.AM
NE>> OHEF O TSHI TNG IHI TNK
T ABOUENWH ID REAOU YRRI WNGTI
IL FEEIK LE'M I GONGOI TSE U A
TWORDT'THA I AS BADAP RS IT'
VE
ER,RY VYOR IMPNTTA.
F CIANLEE THE ETION
OO AIN B LK TEIKSHI I CANL FEE
NGETH AER I CANEE F YLOU
SEETNGHI.
S ITR CON LLEOLDEIK A
LIBUBB ANGND AOTAC R NEOT
OVG OWFLIN R NISOTNIUING
YTEVERNGHI.
BUTNGLI APPHE T ATEPRROIA
VELEL.
TWHAT DTHA IS,OECH TEA A
WRLAGIN C I ASSND SAY
RYNTCORAHAO T WTOU YHI TNKOU Y
YOU TAV HE POUTR YOUEA HRT
TOINHIOM SETNG.
MN'ESTASNEA HEO T B A
T-FIRS PRSPEONUTCEIE BHERE
B TSO AERA TNCFENSRE
TEE
GYENEREEOU Y FL INELOU YRSF
HA
ETOS  BCTON CDUOU TEDHR
GE FURINO IRSNTHE T KDBOEYAR.YO
I
WDEONRHAT YROULSIT RUA
AR
E.
H YDOOUE TM CAL
OW DN?
OUOBVIAVYSL HE CVERSIOATNS
NEONLIBO AUT THET SORF O
ING.
OATWH TRI WTEHE WNOU Y
E'R
INFEEL O IGTT WRHAO D YOU DO?
>>ISXE-ERC TEOE BER VY
FO INGSI, LUN R A.OT
TE LIIS TNOUS MIC.
DESTHE MSAY I LTLOSY TTEISN
SSRDWOLEUS MIC.
EN HIAVZ J'TAZYL PLAHATSIS T
T
UNI R IO TTEL HPS MEUS FOC.
VEHA AER VYEI WRDISLA PYL IT
LI T TENOT'SEALLT JYUS
FORE MON SHAGS TOULD WOU
PET NOEX H TCTOREAEA BTSWO T.
ITDIN IS I TES BTORITE IN
INMOE RN FGORE M.
NK TIHI ATOM SOIE PNNT I
ELLCOEGLD C IOUTE WRIT I
AN OIMYTE D TFHE I,AY C
LDOU
PSLEEATND A E AT ANYIM TEF O
DATHE Y.
HETBU T ILD OER GETT' IS
HA
ORERRD F ME.
D FIN A LOTF O C IFOOMRT
N
INKEEP MYITUALSDI PREABCTLE
VID ANHACI SNGPECFIIM TESF O
TH
W DEAYOREHE DPE SFICIC
GSTHIN.
BUHE TUM NNERBE ONG THI I
YSALWA TAV HE I DOOS IAV H TEO
NRU.
TIT'SEN AHEDRINALE FMRO
GINNNG TASREESEL WHEHE IN
BYOURNDINRA AYEA RLLOUET G Y
NGINTHKI AUTBOHA WTOU YT WAN
TO AAY SOWND HOU YAN WOT T S
IT.
EDLI FTEFOU Y BNDEOR AFT AER.
BE>> REFO.
OOK AY TIOBVUSOUTHA C
BE
AHERE DLLAYUT BOU YAV HEO T
GOHE A.AD
WE>> O H QEAV ATEUI F
EW
TIQUESORSON FUDUR O A
NCIE.
ILWE W T GLETEW AO FF O
TH
SHI TNKEOMRE AIR DTEECD A
T
BO O OTHFURST GUESHTON TIG
.YO
T CUANHIEAK TS WEVHOER
D WOULOKELI T OUM JP THA
ES
QU
ONTI.
I'E LDIK BO T OEHEF T QNSTUEIO
FOATEV VIERSWEED NAM
AULPAOPPROSIT WHRU TMP
UNANNOAWNGCI LITSUSGA A
STIN
SOTHE ALCIED MIAPA COMESNI
TOY.
ANWHO CLOC SIAIA MED BED HEL
BLUNCOTA IFOE RTSLE COLIVCTEAC
NLERO IROHE T PTIONF
CRLTUEY?
'T D ION TNO KWNSHE AORWE T
TH
ATUESTN.
DWOI ULHEAY S TOM'SRE S
HIG
HETO TMI PRESE.
HII TIA SNKOC MED THRESIV
ONICON CFL.T
ANTINC IENZEVIDTI PARLACUR
C ONDFCEONPTENET BWE PPLEOE
WH
EEER WASRE A HN O CBLRIHATA
ES
BLOS PSI TEOH EACER OTH AND
TINTCOESNGENRG AUMT.
I'T KWHA WT THEUT SOLNIO
T TTOHAS I.
E HWEAVIR A F ANTNDMEME.
YO FNNCAOTCETERI PVA
COTOIEANS SE UITLG AORSHM
TH
AR RATEWFL CDONTICES LS.
I TPOUPSENLHE O WY TAYOO D
TH
ATS IIM SOYPL T LVEEAHE T
ATFONSRM IIRHE T FSTLA PCE.
WHEC AH D TIOISN
THA I
RE AECSPTND AIRDME.
IONKHI T THEEN EXT WEAV HE
TH
ER PEOWO TEHA CNGHA TT IYS B
RMATPLFOONASS  C TMESURST'HAS
ATT NOWHE WT WAN.
>> OE ONOFURIEWE, L
RAAU
DSAYS H YOOUNYEAV A
DAMMCOEN FONTISS WORAYO T
WGAENGERUHIT TMPUP SSRTPOER
OLTO H ADIR M TRROHEO T
IR
ONACTIHESOS  T A CYANELURCCAT
YE
THE EEF RNCTLEIO?
ON I>> DNK T'THI IHE TRE AS
IASPEC, WLAY SRU TMPERPOUPRT
SAR
EPL PEOE.
THEORE A POUEPL YIS DREAGE
WI
TH.
THERS NOAG MICAY WO T
DISAEEIT WH.
PPHE A AACROHNDIK L YEOUOU WLD
APNYCHOA AELS EE BUTOU Y
DI
WGRSAEENDHIT A TEL TLMHE
WH
TYOHE TEN EXTHAT TTS IVEN
XTETH ETTEN IS IPRPP AROTEIA
DTOOHA TT.
I'OT NMEEC ROM AINNDG OONNYER
RU SND ARGRTTA A WENUMTSHIT
STERNGS.
UNELUNRTAT T IYNTE UHENI
DST
SESAT IY V AERROAN DGEUS
AC.TYVI
IK'SIT LTH AENYGINLS EE.
TOE SOMTXT EEN DISENREAGEMT AS
FRTPA OOC D AEM
CYRA.
PTHEPOURSE OFOC DEMCYRA IS TO
CLVSOETFLONICUTIT WHO
BL
D.DSOOHE
IT T NSOTE HOAV CO NTFLONIC
AT ALL.
WEAY AELWNG GSOIO T
CALIPOTILREIS DAG.ENEMTS
THLWE'R ASAY GNGOIO TE
PEH WLEITRVON CSE VIVATEWSIE
IG RONELN,IONO ECOCSMI,ND A I
ONINTHK NG TEHI WEHO SODUL D
ER GINEN U IALSANERNDST WDE
AR GVENERNG T LIVNE I A
WIRLWOD OUTHT DEMAGISRETEN.
WE
LLCT AUALD WYOUOT N WTAN
O.
TO
MYONECBJTIROND A TSSMPI I
NO THAT TYHE DEAGISRE.
IR T'SHE DEMAGISRETSENE HAV
DLEM THEO T P ACELAHE WREY THE
TTEAR APTIN TONG CHAHEE T
CALIPOTILTE SYSM.
AG DTOISITERE WM THHE
POYCATILLEVY B S TINERGMHE
OMHE TRANCSEHIE WRE A
ALNG GYSOIAVO T HE
DIGREENTMEAN C'TO DHA T ITF
ISIN ASKGHI T INKTESPP ALIOH
OBOTHF Y
.OU
IT FLS LEIK AY MAN
DUDIINVIITSAL WH CICOM BKOO
REGIN BUNKGACRO ODSFHO TSE
SP
AKIEANGTI WNDRI WIT
YARCLITHEN I TRU TMPA ARE
EWHER HHE TYHEPEL TAL MOR
TADEUNRS
INNDG?
OLEX T MHANSSHI ING GOI TO
GE
IT AT LETLEI W.RD
MYOR FAVOMEIT CICOO BK
CH STEACRN.ERUPMA
IUPEOV S TMAERNO DTHEA.
>> MSOHUCHA TST'ER INTTIESNG
AOUABT HARAER W IHOSS A A
STILID DLECESIOON CSCLYUSO T
ISEUS H AOW PER AND TAY WO
EOLPHE PEPL.
IRMPEAN SSO BGFLAFINO T
OPPELE YOUEE S THE TRYOGIN T
RE SINAGENERUPMAHES A T ELVI
ORCTDIAT.
ATHEY SUMSSE WEOOMNEHITT THA
KIND PF OEROWOU WLD BE PRED
IWITHTIERNTESUT ANGBO
SUSANRM IEHY W HOTID D N
HOKETA TSE PNSITOSIO.
IHI TNKT JUS AS ANACRT AIF OTF
JE
MESHWI A CCARIN HTUULRE IES
FA
ININSCATG.
TIMISILAO INGNTRI AMENCA
FELIGHHR TOU A FM INSAN KSA
BU RTI SLLNGAIEMNI FPA ARTMRO
AMAN SIETY.
INTHKOM CICOO B
AKSRE
TAFOLKS.LE
SLVIOBOU H WYEEAVMERINCA
LELKFOTAHIIS  TRE TNKHES I A
SH
OREDAR MALRSNI UVE TREHE
THATSOURE PCIS.
OBISLOUY NDAN C UDSTERANHY W
PSOMEPLEOERE AED TIR OFEI BNG
SA
DRATUTEY B CIAMEOMRCL
B UITQUY.
TBU, IOU FNDSOM CICOE
ATEOFN WULDEONRFAY W TO
EX MORPLEALORPL COMSITEXIE
IEVEN TNHETYBI ALI WEAV H
E
BNOTD GEOO AT ALL.
PL P>>EO'T DEONNO KWE WND SPE
STE THLAINEN T MIMESUT TUTE B
E SNERYDPTON CCE.
NK TIHIT'S CTUTRONACLYAL
.
TEAU[LGHIT
G TUOM TETHEN IROUB.
TRETH SLTUUCRANG CHAHEE T
ASTSYEMS IT IS IER UND IANSTD
TKEASDUESHI Q IIOSTNM A
OT N
PTHE TSOERNO A
.SK
ITHIS TSHEIN KD OFUE QIOSTN
WHAT CAN THE DTSOCEMRAO? D
MI AOT N P AALITOLIC
ST IGITESTOTM A N A
DEECTTEIV IS.
DIO KOT NHEWNO TTE SPSO T
CUS JT
TING ARET BTEOR ME
RLWOD.
ANI CIBES DCR W TEHE WLDORE
ARNDN I AHY W A IREN. ITS
WATTH'S FTHA IIKLEE LYE M
LEROS. I
BUN I TMSERF OHA CINNGG T
HE
DWORLHEOR F TRET BTE'SHE TRE A
T LOOF WULDEONRFLL B,RINTIA
WOPPELE W AHORE OKIORNGN TTHA.
ANAST I W A DIFCULT
ESQUOOONTI T.
>>OUARNDHE TRYOU CNTS A AFEHORO
ITNYMA STE WESESET JRNUN
NTH
HERE INSA TULND AEE WKSFT AER
GE
LOGEOR FND'SYD AURDE
P TRUMDCIDEDEOSO T H HT
IS
TFIRSALLYNUN JHEEETNT
WH I IHS ANNDF OTS IFEL
BEY TREHEEDHA CNG ITAS W A
RUSTMO CEL A.CT
T SA OHE TERNE HAMNMA C
E
EES Y H RIE DDHTIGFT AER
THAT TTHATOM MEN O CFRSOUE
EY C INGHAE TTOHE T DAY
AFRTEOR
DSOR.
NENO OEAAD H HUT ARDBO
EV
ENHAPPER AEDFTHA TT.
THOMEN, CGATHEIN DHA TT
AY
AWAS OER VYCTRTVE AO TE M OF
CRNDYLT ASI U TNGHEEGTR SAT
Y
LKU YOTA.BO AUT
OTHENRS CFOU OENEEA YR LATER
AWERE IN AER VIFY DREFENT
PL FEORHE CTIEBELRA WONAS
VE AUC MHIF DREFENTNG THI
.
OUKAS YHI TS, DO YOUEE FLN I
TH
OATNE YREA TEIMOU YEE S A
FTLO OGR PRO?SIESON
ISNSHI ALYNO AMA D,OF IIK LE
TH G AGSRETIETNG BTER
Y?ICQUKL
ALHAT A TEN MTOMT
ECSPLYICIFAL D YOOUEE SHA TT
AS THEGE LARR STEWOMHAEUB STL
OWAYNG DFOIRU CEL ASCT ON A
SIBVSUEREL LVEEV AT' ISIG B
QUONTI.
JU >>I T WSTANO THO SUTUT O
RTHENGAIEMNIVOUR SVI T ORFHE
TU
ALSSA MASHOECR WUS J
T
IFTESTDIEEF BEOR CSGRONES IS
VESSEP DREHEGIN TLL SYTI
HAHE TIRIT WOSSNE T TSEHO
EV R TTSOIAELNT AND TOEA L
RR
.OM
NK TIHI ERU TMPDELXCLET A
IOOCOVATN.
T S APLIMY ASN ACTF O
YUECRLTUT BIN MAKGEO PEPL
D.MA
NK TIHIHA TTLI ABI TTYOAK ME
MOPPELE A WADASOU SERC OF
PL FSUEAREY MORAN HF O
ISSU
RSORPPTE
CIAL IFE HEL F LT TEIKHE
PRIOOCOVATN,VEN IFHE T
ATOVPROCASNIO WIB DELATERE THE
FE
R TLTHENCTEAIOAS W
UNDIFSTIER OGG EXAATERED,
THHEREMO TNJY EEDOY IT.
INK THITH WHE OERROT NT I WAS
HEL,UE WER O NOT T
MPRU
ENEVND UDSTEROOHA WT H WEAS
DO B TG,OES HEON ITNHA TT
ULRTPAICTA IARNS AENC IMOT N
SUE HSTND UERHEDOO T
ICGNSIIFFCEAN OEEUN JETHEHNT T
ICGNSIIFFTAN OGAV HINLY R AAL
ATTHA TEIM.
HE E POYNJEDNGVOROKIE.EO PPL
IT
T P'SAROWF O HE
MOSLIPOZEHE T ENOCOMYF O
IOTEATNTT TNHAOS I SOURE PCI
S
INICOL PITS.
A WATASXAN ELEMPF OT IE H
ONLLWI CNUEO USET THA
ESCALEEO T KSE HPIMLF A
NTLEREVA WTHHEER OR NOT H
E
UEPURS PTHS ENCSIREDEYIN AGA.
HE>> T AOO BK TTHEEL CRUTYLL A
YOFOU H AEAV C OYOP IFT.
IIV DEDONTT IDYLR AEA ISHE
GGOINNEO T O OF THEOS MT
ANPOIMRTKS BTOOHEF O TEA YRN I
AATVEONRSHANIO T W YTOUTAN
A BTOE PTAR O
PEI HOOU Y A WLL SLILNDPEOM SE
TI
DI RMEEA THA IN THE
MICONGAY D
S.
NTI WA SO TAY A BIGHA TNKOU Y
GR CDONIOULATATNSR YOU N
EWN
VEIT ERYXC H TEDO AREAUTBO
ATTH.
OUOF CURERS OPE S GALCI
STUE
"NK YEWOR"IM TESELES BTSRLE
MUVEES-DER IAND DIS WH YOU
ALLNDIL WLAL T TKON DOW THEWE
RONK T,HAENOU Y G FEMTLEN
ORO
E. TURIM
THKS FIN HORAVGS